nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
direction les Caraïbes et plus
précisément la grande île d'ispanella
que ce partage Haïti à l'ouest l'un des
pays les plus pauvres au monde et la
République dominicaine à l'Est qui au
contraire affiche une croissance
économique que bien des pays lui ont
envie grâce au tourisme notamment face à
ce déséquilibre terrible les autorités
de la République Dominicaine ont décidé
de construire un mur pour endiguer toute
forme de trafic une séparation physique
en rouge sur cette carte qui vient
s'ajouter au mur du racisme et de la
xénophobie des Dominicains à l'égard des
Haïtiens Laurence cuvilliers
correspondante de France 24 dans cette
zone des Caraïbes on vous retrouve en
direct vous êtes à Mexico on va
découvrir leur portage que vous avez
tourné sur la construction de ce mur
dans quelles circonstances la décision
de le construire a-t-elle été prise
qui va séparer deux voisins qui ont bien
du mal à partager ce petit espace qui
est l'île d'Hispaniola les Haïtiens et
les dominicains ne parlent pas la même
langue il y a peu de projets
transfrontaliers dans l'histoire a été
marquée par des conflits des
affrontements des tentatives d'invasion
des massacres on va le voir la maison
aujourd'hui la situation dramatique sont
au niveau économique que politique
sécuritaire et sanitaire fait qu'ils
sont des centaines de milliers de
haïtiens à vouloir trouver refuge chez
leurs voisins Dominicains et c'est cette
migration massive doublée d'un profond
racisme à l'égard des haïtiennes que
veulent tendiguer les autorités
dominicaines avec ce mur alors on vous
retrouve dans un instant Laurence après
la diffusion de ce reportage que vous
avez tourné Haïti République Dominicaine
l'île fracturé reportage tourné avec
Mathieu commun
[Musique]
ce bébé vient de naître
et il lutte pour sa survie
[Musique]
sa mère haïtienne est arrivée dans cette
clinique de République Dominicaine après
avoir traversé la frontière un long
trajet à pied en plein travail avant
même l'accouchement le bébé était déjà
épuisé mais ce petit hôpital de la ville
frontière de pederne Alès manque de
moyens pour le sauver
il est dans un état critique et on n'a
pas pu l'intubé
s'il reste ici il y a une forte
probabilité qu'il meurt on a besoin
d'aide d'un transport d'une place
quelque part
une situation courante le long d'une
frontière qui sépare Haïti le pays le
plus pauvre des Amériques et la
République dominicaine l'économie la
plus dynamique de la même zone
un sillon de 376 km qui commence ici un
estuaire que l'on peut traverser à pied
une simple borne marque la division dans
ce paysage paisible
mais si on longe la rivière 15 km vers
le sud un mur est en pleine construction
il mesure à 200 km c'est le gouvernement
Dominique qui a lancé le projet avec
l'appui d'une large majorité de la
population et même de ceux qui en seront
gravement affectés Mildred est éleveuse
pour ce mur nous sommes complètement
d'accord pour la sécurité de notre pays
et de ses habitants
ce terrain était leur prairie le
gouvernement dominicain vient de
décréter qu'une frange de 200 mètres de
large de chaque côté du mur sera déclaré
d'utilité publique j'ai lu le décret il
dit qu'il s'agira d'une frange de 200
mètres de large c'est-à-dire que notre
fine cas sera rayé de la carte et on va
devoir arrêter l'élevage notre seule
source de revenus
midred n'a encore reçu aucune garantie
sur une compensation financière de la
part de l'État aujourd'hui et pour
quelques semaines encore elle peut
partager un moment avec des enfants
haïtiens sur les berges de la rivière
mais quand le mur sera terminé c'est de
monde seront séparés
c'est une rivière binationale pourquoi
porte-t-elle ce nom
je ne veux pas parler de ça
d'une page noire de l'histoire de l'île
en 1937 entre 20000 et 35000 haïtiens
furent massacrés un permis de tuer donné
par le Président dominicain de l'époque
Raphaël tourillon les haïtiens qui
travaillaient pour les compagnies
sucrières américaines au dominicaines
étaient constamment victime de racisme
la méfiance entre les deux nations ne
s'est jamais vraiment éteinte
dans cette région d'élevage l'idée du
mur est dans les esprits depuis
longtemps
Nelson et ignaccio sont frères malgré
leur grand âge il surveille leurs vaches
armes à l'épaule toute la journée
j'ai mis cinq cartouches
Haïti c'est un immense repère de voleur
vous m'entendez
leur enclos surplombe la rivière
binationale
un jour à haïtien mon volet un troupeau
complet de 14 vaches avec leur veau
ils ne m'ont rien laissé
et je n'ai jamais eu d'aide de la part
des autorités
on a dû investir beaucoup pour
construire ces murs installer des
clôtures et des protections en tout
genre
parce que toutes les nuits des Haïtiens
traversaient pour prendre des vaches
l'absence de coordination entre les
autorités des deux pays a laissé les
éleveurs dans le désarroi face aux
pertes de bétail
à quelques kilomètres de lin haïtien the
dominicain ce que toi de bien plus près
nous sommes du côté haïtien dans la
ville frontière de wanama
vendredi jour de marché binational 8h du
matin sur le pont qui enjambe la rivière
des milliers de Haïtiens se préparent à
traverser les jours de marché ils
peuvent se rendre en République
Dominicaine sans papier ils y vont pour
vendre un peu de marchandises ou comme
Lionel pour chercher du travail
parfois j'aide un commerçant à vendre
ou si quelqu'un a besoin de traduction
du créole à l'espagnol j'offre mes
services
lionel est haïtien mais il a vécu
plusieurs années en République
Dominicaine avant d'être expulsé faute
de papier la frontière s'ouvre le début
d'une ruée vers les meilleures
emplacements
attention ça commence ce marché
n'abobine nationale que le nom la
République Dominicaine protège sa bonne
santé commerciale ici les produits
Haïtiens sont considérés comme de la
contrebande les Haïtiens en sont réduits
à acheter des produits dominicains pour
les revendre avec des marges dérisoires
ce qui asphyxie encore un peu plus la
fragile économie haïtienne
est-ce que tu as besoin d'aide
aujourd'hui
dans ce marché saturé il y a trop de
bras et pas assez de travail
je peux vous aider à charger ces bananes
tout le matin j'ai besoin de deux
personnes mais je les ai déjà trouvé
il n'y a plus de travail nulle part
Léonel devra rentrer chez lui les mains
vides aujourd'hui
à combien tu vends le Yuka
il aurait aimé acheter un peu de
nourriture côté Dominique car en Haïti
les prix ont flambé de 26% en un an
Leonel vit avec sa fiancée Elisette à
wanamment ici pas de courant ni
d'électricité avec la sécheresse le
puits est presque à sec
il n'y a presque plus d'eau regardez la
longueur de la corde j'ai dû aller très
profonde
il paye l'équivalent de 35 euros de
loyer par mois pour une petite pièce
sans aucun confort
quand je vivais en République
Dominicaine j'avais un frigo une
gazinière et l'eau courante
Léonel a laissé sa mère et son fils de 5
ans à Saint-Domingue la capitale de
République Dominicaine il ne les a pas
vu depuis deux ans
j'espère que Dieu me donnera la chance
de retourner là-bas
nous continuons notre route vers le sud
au centre de Lille c'est un chemin
rocailleux qui sépare les deux pays sur
plus de 70 km bordée de hameaux presque
coupé du monde
au kilomètre 106 nous faisons une
étrange rencontre
Thomas beyerline est un militaire
allemand à la retraite
il vit ici avec Elena sa femme haïtienne
et leur fille d'un an et demi
ça c'est notre maison
de ma femme n'est pas contente elle
voudrait une maison luxueuse
moi j'aimerais mieux vivre en République
Dominicaine
là-bas c'est plus tranquille il y a du
travail ici il y a rien même si tu crées
un petit commerce les gens n'ont rien
dans les poches pour acheter quoi que ce
soit
la petite famille mène une vie simple
faite de jardinage de séance de coiffure
et de bricolage Thomas c'est aussi bien
adapté à la culture locale
par exemple si jamais un voleur ou une
personne mal intentionnée entre ici
en a deux trois ou quatre jours il va
tomber malade
où il va mourir
c'est du vaudou oui c'est du vaudou
tombé amoureux de l'île après de
nombreux voyages il a rencontré Elena et
n'est plus reparti depuis trois ans
j'ai vécu 50 ans dans le luxe en
Allemagne j'avais tout ce que je voulais
mais je savais que ça ne me rendrait pas
heureux
je préfère vivre modestement ici je n'ai
pas besoin de grand-chose
on vit très bien avec ma petite pension
de militaire à la retraite
Elena a pu obtenir son passeport mais il
ne lui donne pas le droit de vivre en
République Dominicaine
j'ai le passeport mais pas le visa et le
visa coûte 400 dollars pour seulement un
an
pour eux ici un mur n'aurait aucun sens
les habitants ne sortent guerre du
village que pour emmener pétrole leur
chèvre
[Musique]
alors qu'à l'extrême sud de l'île où la
frontière rencontre de nouveaux la mer
des Caraïbes la ville dominicaine de
pederneales attend le début des travaux
pour les habitants de la ville jumelles
haïtienne dans sapintre la vie
quotidienne est encore faite de
traverser informelles et de commerce à
la sauvette
cette rivière là c'est la frontière de
l'autre côté c'est la République
Dominicaine ce jeune homme là qui
traversent la frontière presque tous les
jours ces activités de l'autre côté il y
a des militaires 2
militaires par point mais pour les gens
se traverse surtout dans les points
informels il faut donner quelques
quelques sous quelques petits argent à
des militaires Jean fait partie du
service jésuite aux migrants une
association qui aide les expulsés
haïtiens parfois traumatisés par la
violence des autorités dominicaines
sur cette vidéo amateur un militaire
dominicain rudoit un migrant haïtien des
traitements courants sur l'île l'immense
majorité du demi-million de haïtiens qui
vivent en République Dominicaine est en
situation irrégulière plusieurs milliers
sont expulsés chaque mois dans ce
quartier dans chapitre la majorité des
habitants sont des rapatriés qui
traversent la frontière clandestinement
chaque jour pour le trafic de bois
c'est comme ça que ça se passe on va
couper du bois en République Dominicaine
pour le revendre ici et gagner notre vie
ici tout le monde fait ça
les militaires nous poursuivent quand on
se fait pincer il nous prennent le bois
il nous roue de coup
mais tu peux avoir de la chance et
passer inaperçu
le manque d'électricité en Haïti a
provoqué un retour au charbon de bois
d'où l'importance de ce commerce légal
ce ne sera pas bon pour nous
parce qu'ici tout le monde gagne son
pain en République Dominicaine c'est
notre seul recours
retour à l'hôpital de pederne Alès
regarde tu l'as tellement bien
emmailloté il dort comme un ange
le bébé a survécu mais les médecins ont
été sur le pont toute la nuit
cette nuit il y a eu en plus une
césarienne et deux accouchements tous de
femmes haïtiennes et un accouchement
d'une femme Dominicaine
ici cette passion sur dix sont de
nationalités haïtienne
regardez madame c'est votre bébé elle
parle espagnol non ne le parle pas vous
pourriez nous aider à traduire
j'ai pas trouvé d'hôpital pour me
recevoir
[Musique]
le nouveau-né va être transféré dans un
hôpital spécialisé
c'est vraiment soulagée qu'il s'en soit
sorti mais qu'on souhaite n'aura pas le
temps de souffler les patients haïtiens
arrivent souvent dans un état critique
l'insécurité sur les routes les empêche
d'aller chercher des soins médicaux à la
capitale Port-au-Prince et la flambée
des prix aggrave tous les problèmes
cette petite a un mois
mais elle est très en dessous du poids
qu'elle devrait avoir à son âge
dominicaine entre les deux pays la
frontière ressemble à un abime un
déséquilibre économique sanitaire
sécurité alors que Haïti s'enfonce dans
la crise sur tous les fronts la
République Dominicaine tient plus que
jamais à protéger son envol économique
porté par la manne touristique
on retrouve Laurence Cuvillier de retour
d'Haïti Laurence pour les Haïtiens ce
mur semble n'avoir que des désavantages
en particulier pour les haïtiens qui
vivent en zone frontalière pourquoi la
situation est-elle particulièrement
grave pour eux
imaginez vous êtes un agriculteur qui
vit en zone frontalière par exemple vous
produisez des bananes vous ne pouvez pas
aller vendre en République Dominicaine
car les Dominicains sont aussi des
producteurs de bananes et on l'a vu il
protège leur marché national la
frontière vous est donc fermé mais vous
ne pouvez pas non plus aller vendre
votre production dans la capitale
haïtienne pour au prince parce que les
routes qui relient la frontière à la
ville sont contrôlés par des bandes
criminelles donc malheureusement il y a
fort à Paris que votre production
pourrira sur place le marché local
extrêmement pauvre ne pourra pas
absorber vos fruits et vous allez cesser
de produire c'est comme ça qu'ait-il
s'enfonce toujours un peu plus dans une
impasse économique on va écouter ce
qu'on dit Jean écart du service jésuite
d'aide aux migrants
on n'a pas de production nationale
au niveau d'agriculture tout ça et c'est
trop Malo n'a pas une politique publique
pour renforcer notre agriculture on n'a
pas de productions tous les jours au
marché binational au marché frontalier
et les gens se les Haïtiens traversent
pour acheter ok pour acheter et revendre
en Haïti on n'a pas de possibilité de
transporter au déporter notre produit au
marché binational et c'est seulement les
ailitera vs pour acheter c'est pour ça
je dis nous sommes des consommateurs
alors le paradoxe Laurent c'est que la
République dominicaine a besoin de ses
haïtiens pour consolider son économie
qui est en pleine expansion
oui tout à l'heure dominicain en
particulier dans le secteur de la
construction et du tourisme ont besoin
de la main d'oeuvre une main d'oeuvre
souvent d'ailleurs non déclarée utilisée
de manière opportuniste sur des périodes
courtes dans les respects de leurs
droits mais avant tout c'est du tourisme
dont a absolument besoin d'un République
Dominicaine pour consolider son goût
méconomique c'est pour cela que le
gouvernement dominicain tente par tous
les moyens de se protéger d'un effet
tâche d'huile de la crise sécuritaire
qui s'est vissé son voisin
merci Laurence Cuvillier correspondante
de France 24 au Mexique c'est la fin de
ce magazine merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
[Musique]